yes so uh this is back at my first job
my first job was at Kroger yeah I worked
as a nonf food stocking clerk which
means I'm in charge of everything that
was not food and so one of my
responsibilities in addition to stocking
the nonf food shelves was to take a
shopping cart and go around every aisle
and pick off things that people leave
behind so people leave like random
things in odd places and I'm supposed to
go grab them put them in a cart push
them to the back so they can be resorted
later um a few weeks into my first job
doing this particular part of my job I
noticed something behind the baby food I
like scooted it aside and I saw a box of
condoms but the problem with this one is
it was torn open right someone had
ripped open a box stolen out some
condoms don't know why just happens but
the first time I had ever seen something
like that and so me being a 15-year-old
I go
what
condoms oh my good like I was actually
like flustered at even the thought of
someone seeing me like even handling
this box of condoms but I put it in the
cart and I started pushing the cart
around and I was like and I didn't have
a girlfriend or anything at the time so
it was like there was no urgent need for
this but for some reason in my mind I
went maybe if I had some condoms maybe I
might be able to have sex someday I'd be
ready for it at least as I'm pushing my
cart through the aisles I start slowing
down physically like the cart because
I'm thinking like okay it's in that it's
in like where you know you you scoot out
the baby thing and was like you would
sit a toddler in there so it's at the
top part of that and I had positioned it
very carefully for there so that as I'm
pushing the cart I could slowly move my
hand like off of the grip and down and
try to grab a condom out of it and I'll
be like I'll just pocket one and then
and then I'll have one and then I will
have the condom power I didn't realize
condom power I didn't realize that you
know I thought all the ladies would be
like whoa you have a condom oh yes I
want you now that looks like the kind of
guy that has a condom in his wallet I
didn't know you were a
man uh
so so so I I reach into the box
eventually after moving to a snails
place cuz I knew they had cameras and
they you know they w i i felt like every
camera was going to look at me as soon
as I started making my move so I had to
move very slowly and I reach in and I'm
like I'll just pull out one and then I
ran into the first problem which condoms
are in a role of perforated string and I
couldn't do this one-handed especially
considering it's a small box and I'm
trying to like stick my hand and there's
not enough room so I'm like I'm
panicking I'm like sweating so uh I I I
bail I bail I stick I I remove my hand
from it I'm like there's no way I can do
this I can't it's not here amongst the
green beans no way I couldn't and I uh I
pushed the card around and then
eventually I made it back to you know
the place if you you probably have seen
it in grocery stores where there's just
a random cart with a bunch of
in it by the back door that's where I
would put it because then they would
take it back and they would store
it so
don't laugh like that ever
again but then I have like this surge of
adrenal and I'm mad cuz I I like lost my
quote unquote chance if the camera saw
me it would look like I was a crypted
cuz I was standing there at that shelf
of like discount items just like fuming
like and then in a flurry of motion I
like reach my hand and rip off one as
fast as I can and then shove it in my
pocket and I just stomped away I stomped
and I sat at the makeup counter and I
just stood there and I sat there and I
didn't finish the job I was doing I
didn't finish collecting all the I
didn't stock any shelf and I just sat
there for like 30 minutes as my heart
was like I did it I went down a rabbit
hole in my own mind of imagining ways
you'd get out of that mhm like he walked
up and you were just like I'm just
counting them to see how many were
stolen several several are missing or
like the manager comes up behind you and
it's like hey what are you doing and
you're like you put your left hand in
and put your left hand out
like I was just using this box to play
this game what are you doing here's a
little balloon
[Laughter]
animal look this is a doggy look it's a
snake what are you doing I have
recreated how the thief did it he put
his hand in the box and then took the
condoms out we should give this
information to the police I'm glad
you're here you're just in time so uh
that's how I got my first condom that
trust me they went unused